I am going to play for you today one of
the most pathetic Donald Trump videos
that I have ever seen of Donald Trump
begging for money mentioning one of
these completely imaginary fundraising
deadlines that are of no meaning or
value whatsoever this guy is desperate
this guy is desperate and it's pathetic
listen to Trump's voice here we have a
major fundraising deadline coming up no
you don't no you this is the biggest
scam we have a deadline it's a
self-imposed deadline we've got to get 5
000 new donors by midnight tonight no
you don't you're just desperate dude and
there's never been a time like this our
country has never been so disrespected
our country has never been so low
certainly in the minds of others and
especially the leaders of other
countries all over the world yeah we
have to change it we have to bring our
country back we made it remember opinion
of the United States around the world
has dramatically improved since Donald
Trump left office every single poll
proves that America great and now we're
going to have to make America great
again yeah so I say whatever you can do
help out we have to meet the deadline
the midterms are coming up it's going to
be one of the most important elections
in the history of our country that's
true only because of the effect it may
have on 2024
so I hope you can help up and help out
we really appreciate it and good luck
yeah can I translate this uh video clip
for you this message here's the
translation
I might actually have to pay my lawyers
this time
okay that's the real message that Donald
Trump is espousing here and look at how
disastrously humiliating fundraising has
been this is an article on Yahoo News
from the Independent Trump's Super PAC
raised just forty dollars in August okay
that's not a typo that's not 40 million
it's not 4 million it's not 400 000.
okay Trump's Super PAC raised 40 dollars
in August former president Donald Trump
Super PAC raised only forty dollars in
the month of August in a sign that his
name doesn't have the fundraising pull
that it once did along with the low
August numbers the make America great
again again Super PAC only raised 351
thousand dollars in July nothing in June
by comparison in the final fundraising
quarter of last year the very same Super
PAC raised between four and five million
dollars even in April and May it raised
864 million dollars among some of the
merchandise that is being made available
are Jared kushner's memoir
Trump wine glasses
and a rally speech signed by Trump as
well as the opportunity to get your name
engraved on a donor wall
now as I mentioned this is really about
legal fees and the article says the
numbers come as save America pack foots
the bill for Trump's legal fees last
month it spent
3.8 million dollars on legal fees the
most spent on such fees the entire 22
2022 cycle with three million dollars
going to critten luddier and Coleman
which is a law firm based in West Palm
Beach Florida remember Maga means making
attorneys get attorneys and Maga also is
extremely lucrative for lawyers that's
for damn sure as you know Trump is going
to have legal fees because of the
Leticia James criminal referral and
lawsuit and we've got what's happening
in Georgia and we've got the Florida
situation with the Mar-A-Lago raid this
guy is going to have legal fees up the
Wazoo so when Trump shows up and he's uh
in in uh his informal wear right no no
no necktie and says we've got to meet
this fundraising deadline what he means
is I might have to pay my lawyers I
might have to pay my lawyers it is
pathetic and it is humiliating he raised
40 dollars guys forty dollars let's hope
that he raises even less
I often have a very hectic schedule and
I don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below